seat of chucky is a direct sequel to
bride of chucky following up on the
explosive birth of chucky and tiffany's
babies seen at the end of that movie
like bride seed would continue the trend
of medicine drawing our attention to
horror movie tropes and not being so
subtle about its influences last episode
when i talked about bride i mentioned
that this new direction for the
franchise was a direct result of the
scream movies having a huge impact on
our culture for god's sake chucky drag
yourself into the 90s right down to the
new chucky logo containing a spike much
like the letter m in the scream logo the
new logo for seed which would be used
going forward is slightly changed this
time the y is the pointy letter making
it look even more like the scream logo
the opening scene pays homage to
chucky's slasher forefather halloween by
showing the scene through the point of
view of the antagonist just like
halloween's opening but having a clear
dependence on halloween in a way is also
another example of how chucky was
influenced by scream because if you
remember in the original scream the
movie that they all watch at stu's party
is halloween and many of halloween's
tropes come up during the events of that
party
kim
look behind
look behind you turn around behind you
behind you bride was very much
galvanized by scream one and two but
since then a third scream movie was
released and seat of chucky would look
to it for further inspiration to learn
how seed of chucky was a mashup of
several horror concepts stick around to
the end of this video this video is
sponsored by keeps
[Music]
welcome to things you missed seat of
chucky tells the story of the indecisive
intersex interloper known as glenn or
glenda it's not really clear which is
accurate by the end of the movie so i'll
just go with whatever seems appropriate
at the time the entire plot is set into
action when glenn sees the maid in japan
marking on his wrist that matches the
mark that he sees on chucky's wrist when
the doll appears on tv to promote the
movie that's being made about it
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm no orphan after all which is just
wrong it doesn't make sense that chucky
would have a made in japan mark because
we clearly see the doll was created in a
factory in chicago during child's play
too and charles lee ray himself was born
in hackensack new jersey as was glenn
who is live born in the cemetery at the
end of bride that's not going to be my
only accuracy gripe but let's get into
the things you missed
[Music]
after the opening dream scene we find
ourselves in a graveyard where santa
claus or someone posing as him discovers
that he's giving chucky and tiffany a
ride in his sack of toys when chucky
comes face to face with the big man he
makes this discovery
i knew it
you're not real this is an ironic thing
to say because throughout chucky's
entire existence as a doll he's only
able to get away with the things that he
does because nobody believes that he's
real the majority of the public just
thinks he's a regular doll this whole
scene ends up being part of the
production of a movie within the movie
they have to stop filming due to some
technical difficulties in the special
effects department chucky's broke again
this is bloody ridiculous this is a
little nod to what famously went on
behind the scenes of the production of
the 1975 horror film jaws where the
titular shark was an animatronic that
was constantly breaking down and messing
up the shooting schedule
you could hear this
the shark is not working repeat the
shark is not working the concept of a
chucky movie being made within another
chucky movie heavily derives from scream
3. in each of the scream sequels so far
hollywood makes a movie adaptation based
on the events of one of the previous
movies which is referred to in universe
as the stab franchise scream 3 features
actor counterparts of each major
character and seed of chucky goes one
step further by casting jennifer tilly
who played tiffany and bride to play
herself jennifer tilly who is also
playing the adaptation version of
tiffany in the movie within the movie
seat of chucky must take place in a
world not too different from our own
because jennifer mentions that she
thinks she should have played erin
brockovich which her rival julia roberts
won the academy award for best actress
for in 2001. and the oscar goes to
julia roberts
she also makes reference several times
her own oscar nomination in the 1994
film of bullets over broadway
additionally the variety newspaper that
she reads features real articles from
the world of entertainment in 2004 and
we see a magazine later on mentioning
the 2004 spanish horror film rojo sangre
scream 3 came out in 2000 and loved to
parody real life stuff from hollywood
but there's another horror movie that
played even more of a role in
influencing seed and we can find it when
we look to the title of the chucky movie
that's being shot in that second
sequence
we're here in hollywood where production
is underway on the new horror flick
chucky goes psycho the movie they're
making is called chucky ghost psycho and
this movie seed of chucky could be
described as chucky goes psycho that is
the 1960 alfred hitchcock movie psycho
in fact the opening dream scene that i
mentioned earlier features a woman
getting stabbed in the shower and
pulling the shower curtain down as she
falls just like the famous shower scene
in psycho that i think i've mentioned
about a hundred times on things you miss
now there's also the fact that the
ventriloquist act that glenn is a part
of in the beginning is put on by a guy
named sykes for this next one i've gotta
spoil the end of psycho it's one of the
all-time great endings so if you haven't
seen it go check it out first if you
have seen it you already know that the
motel operator norman bates has
dissociative identity disorder a mental
condition causing a person to have
multiple identities and sets of behavior
that they switch between at various
times in psycho norman switches between
himself and his mother norma bates
causing him to sometimes act as a
hospitable civil male and sometimes as
an evil homicidal female chucky's
offspring has a similar disorder when
chucky and tiffany first meet the kid
they're unable to determine the gender
chucky names him glenn and treats him as
a male who isn't comfortable with any of
the killing going on around him but
later in the story he switches to female
and assumes the name glenda which was
given to him by tiffany and the female
identity turns out to be a psychotic
killing machine glenn he's an angel an
absolute dream
but glenda
she's a bad girl miss tilly
a very bad girl when assuming the glenda
identity the child even dresses up in a
white dress just as norman dresses up in
his mother's robes the seemingly endless
waterfall of references does not end
there though and we still haven't even
talked about this book and the rest of
the things you missed
[Music]
in bride of truckee we saw tiffany
trying to rebuild chucky using the
shredded pieces of his body and that
involved her just stapling the hair back
onto his head i'm here to tell you that
there is a better way two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
and the best way to prevent hair loss is
to do something about it while you still
have hair left that's where keeps comes
in keeps is a service that aims to make
it easier and more affordable for men to
keep their hair that's why it's called
keeps you see how much you're learning
already everything is done online a
licensed doctor will review your
information recommend the right
treatment for you and have the goods
shipped directly to your door by
prescribing generic versions of fda
approved medications for hair loss keeps
is more affordable plus you can track
your progress with the keeps tracking
tool and message your doctor 24 7 for
questions and updates keeps treatments
typically take four to six months to
start seeing results so if you're
experiencing hair loss it's important to
get on that asap so here's what you need
to do go to the link in the description
that's keeps.com cz and you will receive
50 off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash cz to keep your hair with
keeps
jennifer tilly pursues a new acting role
as the virgin mary the biblical figure
who supposedly magically becomes
pregnant this could be another example
of the movie calling attention to the
fact that it's a movie because our story
in seed is also about a jennifer tilly
character's pregnancy she takes a
meeting with the director redman and in
his office you see a poster of the movie
scarface perhaps a reference to the fact
that chucky has stitches on his face
during this arc or maybe redmond just
really likes al pacino after realizing
he's chucky and tiffany's son glenn
ships himself to the movie studio in
hollywood and again like in child's play
3 we have no idea how he accomplished
this because how did he pack and ship
himself when he's already inside the box
so let's just look past that he arrives
in a special effects shop and sees other
horror icons waiting there but his
interest is in his parents and he tries
one of the dumbella spells to awaken
them and as you probably know it works
which means these dolls that were being
used as props in the chuck ego psycho
movie were the actual dolls from the
crime scene in 1999 because chucky can't
just spawn into any old good guy doll
not yet anyways we see the original doll
cleaned up and rebuilt in child's play
too then that doll is melted down and
the plastic is used to create a new good
guy doll in child supply 3. then the
pieces of that doll are stitched
together in bride and now it appears
that the movie studio somehow ended up
with it and turned him into an
animatronic chucky and tiffany come up
with yet another plan to try to transfer
themselves into human bodies but they
also need a baby's body for glenn to go
into tiffany doesn't want to volunteer
herself though roll it
well i'm not getting pregnant again i'll
tell you that much my mother always told
me once is a blessing twice is a curse i
think this may be an intentional
foreshadowing because when the twins
eventually do pop out later on the first
one is a boy who according to the
babysitter is an angel and the second
one is a girl who's described as a very
bad girl so chucky and tiffany knock up
jennifer with a turkey baster if this
movie came out today i'd probably be
talking about how it drew influence from
don't breathe but i guess it's
technically the other way around i would
think that impregnating her with
chucky's seed would cause the children
to come out half doll but i guess not
i'm not gonna dwell on it also i don't
know if you noticed this or not but when
jennifer calls up her assistant she's
writing fake fan mail letters because
jennifer had mentioned earlier that
she's basically jealous of the
narcissistic pleasures of hollywood
stardom meanwhile tiffany wants to get
rid of her addiction to killing to set a
good example for the baby and this book
tells her she needs to make amends with
those that she has harmed we see her
dial up a woman that she had widowed in
the past
hello good morning is this ruth bailey
speaking the widow of robert bailey yes
who is this she's speaking to the wife
of the police officer that we saw her
kill in the opening scene of bride
whose full name we later see on a news
broadcast to be robert bailey amazing
how they can call back a small detail
like that yet they're unable to remember
the entire crux of the movie the fact
that dolls are not able to drive
themselves kind of makes me crazy
because if it was possible to drive a
car with two dolls then bride doesn't
even need to exist sure i'll steer and
you can work the pedals
we're dolls you dope
i can't see anything
maybe we should slow down i know you're
doing great and the book that tiffany
reads on kicking her addictions is just
so poorly put together they have this
paragraph on the back which was clearly
just copy pasted from somewhere and it
just cuts off mid-sentence once it's
filled up enough space on the cover and
then the page she's reading which is
supposedly page 166 even though it
clearly isn't is the exact same text we
can clearly see that all of the other
pages are blank because the page that
she's reading has colored bars on the
top but the other pages in the book just
don't have that this is just sloppy
filmmaking there's also a shot later
where tiffany is just [ __ ] huge like
that one shot of chucky in the original
movie you may remember one of the gags
in bride of chucky was that tiffany was
a fan of the tridewife tv personality
martha stewart in seed we see a
follow-up on that
they're executing martha stewart this
morning this is a reference to what at
the time was a current event but today
may be forgotten martha stewart went to
prison in 2004 for investment fraud and
lying in court so this is just kind of a
funny escalation of that at one point we
see a bunch of phone numbers listed on
jennifer's landline they're all nine
digit numbers as opposed to the usual 10
digits required for a phone number in
the us but the names are what interest
me the first one is gates which i
imagine is the front gate of the movie
studio and the last one is joan the name
of her assistant the others are just
first names but they do all correspond
to the names of crew members that worked
on the movie they're all common names so
they might not be crew reference easter
eggs but i'm gonna go ahead and assume
they are the story winds down after
chucky decides he actually doesn't want
to transfer into a human body anymore
despite spending the last five movies
trying to do so i'm one of the most
notorious slashers in history and i
don't want to give that up because of
chucky's hesitation the police are able
to save the real jennifer tilly and get
her to the hospital where funny enough
nobody believes her story about the
dolls being alive in this sense she's
kind of the spiritual successor to andy
barkley and like andy she's not in the
clear just yet because at the end of the
movie chucky shows up and smashes
through her door with an axe a clear
reference to jack torrance's most famous
scene in the shine
[Music]
i can't think of a thing to say one of
these days i'll just have to make like a
compilation of every the shining
reference i've pointed out in a movie in
the end chucky loses his limbs just as
he does in each of the original three
movies and gets his head cut off just
like he does in the first one but this
is a clue about the epilogue because if
you've seen that first movie you know
that cutting off chucky's head isn't
enough to finish him and glenn would
find that out five years later
alright i've made it through bride and
seed i didn't think i could do it there
were a lot of long nights of alcohol and
self-mutilation and pouring bleach into
my eyes so if you like these videos it
would mean a lot if you shared them
online the playlist on the left will
eventually contain the next episodes of
chucky things you missed where i'll
covered curse and beyond so make sure
you don't miss out on any of those by
subscribing to cz's world for new
horrors every week ringing the death
bell for all notifications rip martha
stewart and i'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
you